ich habe ja schon oft versucht aus Müll
Gold zu machen und irgendwie Sachen
irgendwo vom Schrottplatz zu nehmen und
die ein bisschen zu restaurieren und
dann auf eBay zu verkaufen für einen
guten Profit das war bisher immer ein
bisschen schwierig die Spitzhacke hier
hat sage und schreibe einen ganzen Euro
erzielt aber es gibt diese Schätze es
gibt Sachen die halt einfach keiner mehr
braucht die ein bisschen Aufwand auf
jeden Fall noch massiv Geld wert werden
man muss nur wissen wo man so glaub
heute habe ich es gefunden und zwar hier
auf Ebay ja nicht kleiner zeigen einfach
wirklich ebay suche ich jetzt mal
Schraubstock rostig dann stellen wir mal
auf Aktion und da ist jetzt also sind
wahre Schätze drin sage ich euch hier
z.B 13 € aktuell geboten hier 15 €
geboten hier 17 € geboten hier ein
Zehner und wir gehen jetzt überall rein
und versuchen Schnäppchen zu schießen ja
hier will z.B für was ähnliches einfach
130 € und da ist jetzt die Idee dass wir
irgendwas rustiges kaufen was wir
irgendwie für so ein Zehner kriegen das
dann schön polieren und dann auch 150 €
so Cash machen hier habe ich noch was
spannendes gefunden vier alte exte steht
h Deko aber wahrscheinlich glaube ich
dass sie nicht Deko sind sondern einf
nur halt so verrostet dass man die nicht
mehr eigentlich benutzen kann aber wir
können die herrichten die Holzstiele
sehen eigentlich auch gut aus kann man
abschleifen D sind die wieder wie neu
dann haben wir hier vier Stück für 40 €
also 10 € pro Stück jetzt schau ich mal
ob es realistisch ist dass wir die für
so viel Geld wieder verkaufen können
hier kostet so ein Kopf auf jeden Fall
schon mal 30 € an sich aber mehr ein
Zehner kriegen wir auf jeden Fall gut
machen wir mal sofort kauf ich hab jetzt
ger noch einen geilen Tisch gefunden
Massivholz ja Tische sind eigentlich mal
ultra teuer aber er ein war 50 € ist
krass also den kriegt man meiner me
locker für 150 € noch mal weg drum
schlag ich jetzt ein Mal zu wunderschön
v te Nachricht jetzt mssen wir noch
abwarten zack ebay hat direkt mal ein
Paket rüber geschickt und idealerweise
sind jetzt vier geile exe drin uh der
hat alte Jeans reingeschickt wi so ja
also Bruder man neue Arbeitsklamotten da
Hotpants Alter will ich wissen was er in
dieser Hose gemacht hat ich glaub es
nicht schick mal ein Bild von dir dann
verkaufe ich das Teil ja auch noch auf
Ebay wahrscheinlich teurer als die EE
hier ja Alter die sind ja riesig das s
ja richtig geile exte ich hatte bisschen
Angst dass die bisschen klein sind aber
die ist ja massive wie wichtig war es
eigentlich dafür diese Hosenbeine
abzuschneiden ich meine das war noch
voll gute Hose jetzt die Frage hat er
die Hosenbeine abgeschnitten um das als
Verpackungsmaterial zu nutzen he das
wird gut aussehen bei dir
Warnung so wir haben ja einmal vier
richtig geile
chte sind alle richtig hart verrostet
aber die beiden sind viel größer als ich
dachte ja also ich dachte nicht dass wir
so große Sachen kriegen die ist halt
wirklich massiv der hol ist auch noch
richtig gut im Schuss müssen wir noch
üerschleifen dann sieht der wieder aus
wie neu dann die Klinge kann man auch
sandstrahlen und schleifen dann sieht
die auch wieder wie neu und ist auch
wieder scharf die hier ist eigentlich in
einem ganz guten Zustand also ich glaube
da spricht jetzt gar nichts dagegen er
hat das selber hier auch mit Epoxy
glaube ich versiegelt wieder sieht auf
jeden Fall bisschen DIY mäßig aus hier
auch wie das runtergelaufen ist aber die
ist gut also ich glaube die wird auch
gut funktionieren und die hier ist auch
ganz geil auch ein guten Griff finde ich
cool also für 40 € das ist heftig ja
also das weiß ich nicht Kollege aber du
hättest dafür auch bestimmt irgendwie 80
gekriegt aber das tun dann hoffentlich
wir Alter die ist so krass wieso ist es
eigentlich so geil eine Axt zu haben BAM
es geht V gut fast so W dafür gemacht
wir haben die Typen jetzt nach
geschrieben dass wir de eine Hose
gefunden haben und ob er die noch mal
braucht ich bin mal gespannt ob er sich
meldet und vor allem was er dann
schreibt in der Zwischenzeit versuche
ich jetzt mal die erste Axt hier zu
zerlegen ich fange einfach mal mit der
größten an ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
leicht oder wie schwer das ist aber hier
wurde jetzt so ein Metallkeil hier
reingetrieben damit das Holz hier in die
Breite gedrückt wird und dann schön fest
drin steckt das
heißt das ist hier tatsächlich auch fest
und ich müss jetzt erstmal den
metallkeit hier
rausziehen gut ich glaube der hilft nur
rausschlagen könnt schwierig werden ist
echt
drin aber ich glaube da geht schon
was die Axt nehme ich da
raus das Ding ist so drin jetzt geht
was
so harter Kampf kommen wir direkt zur
nächsten so Nummer
zwe boah die Dinger halten wirklich was
aus das ist super krass und das ist auch
noch der schönste axts ist richtig
sauber okay der Kollege mit seinen
Jeanshosen hatantwortet ich schau mal
rein geil nein das war Premium
Packmaterial
MFG ja geiler Typ auf jeden Fall Bo ich
habe die beste Idee einfach wir werden
das Premium Packmaterial einfach in
Ehren halten und auch unsere exe wenn
wir die weiter verschicken in seinen
Hosen verschicken ist doch geil oder so
ein achkopf der sieht jetzt z.B so
aus auf jeden Fall schwer oh ich woll
die noch wiegen warte mal kurz die
schwerste ist das die wiegt
1,6 kg die wiegt
1,55 kg die mittlere ungefähr 1 Kilo ja
und wie viel die wegt kann ich nicht
sagen weil das Ding geht ein nicht ab
das Teil ist da bombenfest mit Epoxi
dran da kriege ich jetzt erstmal gar
nichts mehr ab zumindest ohne den Griff
kaputt zuum machen nicht dann geht's
damit jetzt hier zum
[Musik]
sandstrah
ich g am krassesten wird er hier weil er
ist komplett zerstört also das ist Eisen
komplett aufgefressen vom Rost also da
geht gar nichts mehr die Klinge vorne
einfach komplett zerbröckelt schon glaub
das wird das heftigste vorher nachher
überhaupt wir fangen aber mal an mit der
hier die ist noch ein bisschen besser im
Schuss und die kommt jetzt
[Musik]
rein
okay los
geht's und damit sieht die achklinge
jetzt wieder so aus also man sieht
darunter dass die auf jeden Fall schon
richtig hart geed ist ja sieht auch echt
handgeschmedet aus also auf jeden Fall
ist das Ding krum und schief wie sonst
was hinten drauf ja das ist einfach so
ein Wurst einfach nur weil das Teil hier
100 Jahre lang als Hammer benutzt wurde
wier halw Form schleifen ma
bandchleifer
ziemlich coole Sache hier hier sieht man
gerade wieder wie viel Gewicht da mal
eingraviert war 1750 g waren das mal
ziemlich nice das wird das gerade wieder
sichtlich vielleicht kriegen wir das so
hin dass das wieder halbwegs lesellich
ist weil hat man davor eigentlich gar
nicht mehr lesen können weil es mit dem
bandchleifer leider wirklich nur sehr
langsam und mühsam voranging bin ich
dann auf die altbewerte Methode
umgestiegen und habe mir den
Winkelschleifer geschnappt mit dem der
Stall wegging wie Butter egal ob man
jetzt versucht Geld durch den Verkauf
auf eBay zu machen oder durch seinen
richtigen Job es ist eine echte
Challenge dann in Überblick über die
Einnahmen aber vor allem die ganzen
Ausgaben zu behalten mit der App
finanzguru dem Sponsor des heutigen
Videos habt ihr automatisch einen
perfekten Überblick samt Kategorien über
eure Finanzen und seht mit nicen
Grafiken wohin genau euer Geld jeden
Monat eigentlich genau verschwindet egal
ob girirokonto Kreditkarte Depot oder
kryptobörse alles kann automatisch
eingbunden werden ihr müsst also nicht
jede Ausgabe aufwennig einzeln eintragen
wenn euch dadurch dann also auffällt
dass ihr noch dieses eine Abo habt was
ihr schon seit Ewigkeiten kündigen
wolltet kein Problem finanzguru kündigt
den Vertrag einfach für euch komplett
rechts sicher also uch jetzt kostenlos
über den Link in der Videobeschreibung
finanzguru und bekommt als Neukunde mit
dem Code tommery kostenlos finanzguru
Plus für ganze 3 Monate statt der
üblichen 7 Tage damit habt ihr einen
noch tieferen Einblick in eure Finanzen
mit ausführlichen Analysen smarten
budgetvorschlägen Excel Export und eine
Anzeige eures frei verfügbaren
Einkommens bis zum nächsten
Gehaltseingang und wir schauen jetzt
dass wir bald ein Gehaltseingang vom
Möbelverkauf bekommen so und damit haben
wir jetzt schon weiten Weg hinter uns ja
wenn wir uns jetzt mal das hier und das
hier vergleichen das hier sieht schon
sehr geil aus jetzt mir hier so im
direkten vorher nach Vergleich den
machen wir natürlich später auch noch
hübsch aber jetzt machen wir erstmal den
noch hübscher und zwar an der
Poliermaschine so hier ist die
Poliermaschine Pam hier ist die
Polierpaste Pam so das Ding an weil das
ziemlich viel Stau macht se ich eine
Maske
auf so wird das ewig dauern also damit
kommen wir nicht weiter probier noch mal
was anderes und zwar noch mal hier mit
Winkelschleifer nur eben mit einem
[Musik]
Schleifaufsatz J also ist jetzt auf
jeden Fall glossy ja der ist jetzt schon
mal richtig gut und ich glaube jetzt ist
ein Punkt erreicht an dem es auch Sinn
macht den zu polieren und desw ma ich
das
jetzt einfach atberaubben wunderschöner
Stahl dann
[Musik]
ich nur noch eine ordentliche
Schneide
boah ist das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
scharf scharf genug ist übertrieben
poliert haben wir es jetzt auch viel
noch der Stiel und so sieht aktuell aus
abgenutzt ansonsten halbwegs im Schuss
muss gut abschleifen g steckt jetzt noch
er hier drin dieses metallldlding und
jetzt glaube ich kriegen wir das
hentlich
raus boah der ist ja richtig tief drin
gewesen so sieht aus der Schatz den wir
jetzt geborgen haben das Ende ist ein
bisschen hart mitgenommen ich glaube da
kann man nicht mehr viel retten drum se
ich das einfach mal
[Musik]
ab ja das hat jetzt viel besser
funktioniert als der bandsteif drüben
sieht aus wie ein
neu sieht hübsch aus richtig hübsch
sieht Holz erst aus wenn man einölt das
ma wir jetzt ich wollte ja eigentlich
das von Jonas nehmen allerdings riecht
das nach Lavendel aber wenn ihr ein
Käufer von E das Paket aufmacht und das
riecht dann als hät ich das Ding
parfüiert dann kommt das noch komischer
als eine Typ der mir seine abgerissenen
Jeans geschickt hat ja deswegen nehmen
wir
das krass wie das zum Leben kommen ne
geil das sieht richtig geil aus hat
leider hier ein bisschen Holzwurm bin
gespannt ob überhaupt Käufer gibt die
anderen axch sind auf jeden Fall
bisschen besser im Schuss noch jetzt
geht's an den axkopf bzw an die
Vereinigung jetzt muss ich glaube ich
den hier nur noch mal gutes Stück
abschneiden weil da G noch mal kaian
muss schne ich das jetzt erstmal gutes
Stück ab und S mit der Bandsäge guten
Schlitz rein okay aber jetzt kommt der
axkopf da eigentlich drauf der ist jetzt
drauf auch schon halbwegs fest weiß
jetzt nicht ob das ein Problem ist also
mal schauen ob ich da überhaupt jetzt
noch ein Keil reinkriege und wenn ja wie
wie weit manu hat sich da eine dicke
Bohle ah geholt die wir noch von jas
übrig haben und da erstmal an der
Tischkreissäge wilde Winkel gemacht dann
ging es rüber an die Bandsäge wo es
genauso wild weiterging wie es an der
Tischkreissäge schon angefangen hat bis
einige Premium Keile dabei rausgekommen
[Musik]
sind krass wie gut das reingeht noch
okay ich glaube das ist bombenfester
drauf sieht jetzt so aus ich glaube das
SE ich jetzt ein mal kurz
ab oft ist es bei Hammern und bei Exon
so dass da nicht nur so ein Keil
reingeschlagen wird sondern auch noch so
ein Ring ja so ein Metallring so ein
angeschliffener bei dem haben wir
nämlich ganz genauso dann denhen sich
das Holz mal in alle Richtungen aus
richtig wild das haben wir jetzt auchm
hier vorbereitet und eben angeschliffen
und das versuchen wir jetzt auch mal
testweise ins Holz reinzuhauen ob das
schon genug angeschliffen ist oder ob
wir es noch Spitze machen
[Musik]
müssen geht schon rein ja ich glaub der
macht genau das was er soll das sieht
schon ziemlich cool aus ja und das wird
jetzt auch reingehämmert und dann
idealerweise drückst den Stiel hier noch
weiter raus und das Ding hier sitzt noch
bombenfester geil geile Sache Alter also
das Ding ist auf jeden Fall bombenfest
jetzt und damit sollte er jetzt
eigentlich gar kein Problem
sein ja also wenn man treffen würde wäre
das tatsächlich richtig aber ja so viel
Z
Alter
ich traue mich nicht
mehr okay wir haben jetzt hier die
richtige Unterlage und jetzt kann man da
richtig gut drauf loslegen
oh die ist da drin ey ja
Ciao für eine anständige Anzeige auf
Ebay brauchen wir auch anständige Bilder
deswegen erstmal ein provisorisches
Fotostudio einrichten und ein paar
Bilder schießen mit den Bildern unten im
Text den wir natürlich nicht selbst
geschrieben haben sondern jgpt haben wir
die erste Axt für 40 € online gestellt
damit hätten wir den kompletten
Kaufpreis für alle vier exse wieder
reingeholt also zumindest wenn die
irgendeiner will jetzt geht's weiter mit
den anderen Ex ich bin sch richtig
gespannt was wir aus diesem alten
komplett verrosteten Teil noch rausholen
können let's go davor kümmert sich Manu
aber um dieses Schmuckstück die kleinste
der Vichte hier hat der Vorbesitzer den
Stiel mit epoxidat so fest in den
Axtkopf geballert dass der gar nicht
mehr rausging drum haben wir die
samtstiel in den Sandstrahler geworfen
und die kam dann deutlich saauberer
wieder raus der Stiel wird dann noch
geschliffen und so sieht die kine Axt
dann aus rechts daneben seht ihr
übrigens den wohl best erhaltensten
axstiel der vier Hexe die wir gekauft
haben im vorher nachher Vergleich sieht
man richtig was man da noch rausholen
konnte und auf den axstitil kommt jetzt
auch noch der passende axkopf drauf weil
Thomas da jetzt irgendwie ein richtig
geiles Schmuckstück draus gemacht hat es
sieht wirklich krass aus und unsere
andere Axt jetzt irgendwie noch bisschen
langweilig aussieht al hat eine
verrückte Optik aber jetzt irgendwie
keine sehr schöne schnappe ich mir jetzt
unsere esse und dann werden wir das Teil
in Öl so bis bisschen schwarz Brin also
das ist zumindest der
[Musik]
Plan werend die Klinge jetzt da in der
Esse genau auf die perfekte Temperatur
die ich natürlich im Kopf habe und
ausgiebig recherchiert habe
erhitzt währenddessen habe ich mir so
ein Metallbehälter geholt und da schüte
ich jetzt einfach ganz normale
Sonnenblumenöl
rein
tauchen wir die hier mal ganz vorsichtig
ein immer bisschen hin und her bewegen
habe ich
gehört boah das rie wie verbrannte
pommis ja aber das funktioniert sogar GL
ich werde den Vorgang jetzt einfach so
ein zweimal wiederholen ab ich find es
schaut schon richtig gut aus aus
ölbart schön
schwarz und immer noch ziemlich warm
putze jetzt hier mal das restliche Öl ab
und boah krass das hat einfach top
funktioniert zeage ich doch perfekte
Temperaturwahl im Vergleich zu vor hei
die Optik einfach zehn Mal geiler sieh
auch einfach gleich so richtig rustikal
aus wieder ich hier den Griff von der
Axt und den werden wir jetzt erstmal
einölen ganz schön durstig der gute
saugt da ganz schön Weg das
Öl dann stecken wir die zwei hübschen
mal
zusammen
komm den hauen ganz rein
hier das ist so krass wie das
funktioniert einfach diese
Massenträgheit von dieser Axt und der
impulsive Schlag dieses
Hammers muss überhaupt nicht aufstützen
der Luft reinhauen einf bisschen
zusammenklopfen so schaut der AL jetzt
[Musik]
aus die Ache ist jetzt richtig hübsch
geworden ich will die auch jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht ausprobieren ich
weiß nicht hat Thomas mit seiner so wie
das hier aussieht hat der hier wieder
rum rumgehauen wie so ein wie so ein
Einzeller Alter wie der erste Mensch
Werkbank hat wahrscheinlich auch wieder
gelitten so wie ich ihn
[Musik]
kenne ja ich ma jetzt noch ein paar
Fotos von dem Teil und dann stellen wir
das auch auf ebay auch diese Axt braucht
wieder einen treffenden Titel natürlich
auch eine brauchbare Beschreibung und
vor allem fresche Fotos die Ache ist
zwar deutlich kleiner als die erste und
auch nicht so glatt poliert aber der
Griff ist in einem viel besseren Zustand
und deswegen verlangen wir dafür einfach
den gleichen Betrag und dann heißt
wieder warten fehlt noch diese rostige
Axt hier und da ist mir eine Sache
aufgefallen und zwar hat die hier so ein
Schlüsselloch und das muss ja irgendein
Grund haben weil das Ding ist halt keine
Ahnung 100 Jahre alt oder so ist auf
jeden Fall uralt und ist ja auch
handgeschmiedet ja und da ist es halt
schon echt viel Arbeit so ein Ding da
reinzuhauen in der Form glaube ich jetzt
haben wir recherchiert und im Internet
gar nichts gefunden wieso also wozu man
das haben bräuchte weil klar man kann es
damit auf einem Nagel aufhängen du
kannst Hal AX auch einfach so an Nagel
aufhängen habe ich auch so eine
Inschrift gefunden ich weiß nicht ob man
das Lesen kann aber da steht KS also
vielleicht hat es irgendwie der Opa von
Ks Freak geschmiedet vor Ewigkeiten auf
jeden Fall schreibe ich jetzt mal den
ebay verkäufer folgendes kannst du uns
etwas zur ganz alten erzählen okay hat
instant geantwortet er schreibt schade
dass sie keine Zeit haben eine nette
Bewertung zu schreiben ja also ich
erkenne gute Erpressung wenn ich eine
sehe ich glaube der will jetzt einfach
dass wir noch mal dem eine F Sterne
Bewertung geben bevor uns irgendwie
Information rausrückt eben geschehen
haben sie noch Infos zu den Exen
Fragezeichen jetzt aber
bitte die beiden Exel sind jetzt
ungefähr seit zwei Tagen online die
polierte die ich gemacht habe hat zwei
Aufrufe nur und ein Beobachter immerhin
er kann man dem Preisvorschlag senden
ich schreib dir jetzt ein Mal hey wie
wär es denn mit 26 €. die andere Axt hat
sechs Aufrufe aber null Beobachter ja
deswegen keine Ahnung ob sich das
überhaupt noch was ergibt ich glaube ich
mache daraus eine Auktion so D das
Angebot jetzt noch mal online diesmal
aber als Auktion genau wie die anderen
exte kommt auch die verrostetste davon
in den Sandstrahler damit der Rost
abkommt und das Eisen drunter freielegt
wird danach sieht man die Initialien KS
ziemlich gut aber man sieht auch wie
verformt und stumpf die Klinge ist und
deshalb wird die jetzt geschliffen damit
der Axtkopf nicht direkt wieder so
aussieht wie wir bekommen haben Feuer
ich noch mal die Esse an erhitze das
gute Stück und tunst dann wieder ins Öl
wodurch wir hier eine schöne schwarze
Färbung bekommen fehlt noch der uralte
axtstiel bei dem wir erstmal das Ende
abschneiden dann ordentlich was
abschleifen und nach dem Ölen sieht das
wieder aus wie neu damit ist jetzt der
Griff fertig der sieht mega gut aus und
der achkopf der ist auch fertig hat eine
andere Optik als der komplett hochpierte
hier aber auch eine geile Optik das Ding
ist jetzt wieder scharf und idealerweise
hält jetzt noch mal 100 Jahre also jetzt
kommt er hier hier drauf bchen
Gewalt okay ich habe hier ein Problem
und zwar ist jetzt er hier gebrochen
weil ich vergessen habe die Dicke von
dem Teil hier anzupassen darauf ich habe
abgesägt aber da war das Hal ein zu dick
das heiß ich muss noch absägen anpassen
und dann DAF drauf und bevor ich jetzt
weiter machen kann muss er hier erstmal
hier reinpassen und dafür SGE ich ein
bisschen zu oder noch besser nehmen
keine Säge sondern eine
zieglinge das ist das satisfyingste
Werkzeug überhaupt
oh [__] auß man Schneid sich übel rein
what the [__] so er ist verarztet
vorsichtiger geht jetzt
[Musik]
weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so hier geht keine ach über Tresen ohne
dass ich nicht damit einmal mindestens
irgendwas kaputt gehauen hab let's
go zack krass für das Alter
einfach eine richtig schöne acht
[Musik]
geworden ich bin jetzt schon für
Weihnachten bei mein Eltern und die
Auktionen sind jetzt alle durch das
heißt wir haben drei Ex verkauft
schlechte Nachricht die eine diese
geilste die im fern gesehen habt die ich
super klar poliert habe die wollt für 30
€ keiner haben die drei übrigen exte die
wurden verkauft seht ihr gerade ich bin
gespannt welche davon am meisten
reingebracht hat wir fangen mal an mit
der kleinsten oha die ging für 10,50 €
Weg dafür dass ich so klein war
eigentlich ganz okay wir haben vier
echte für 40 € das heißt sie hat ihren
Wert ungefähr wieder reingespielt dann
gehen wir zur zweit kleinsten die geht
raus für 7,80 tatsächlich nur also sogar
noch ein bisschen weniger wir sind ja
nicht auf dem guten Weg ja wir sind
nicht mal auf dem Weg dass wir den W
wieder reinspielen und dann die letzte
Axt ja die älteste Axt die wirklich
uralt ist 4,50 € ja also die kleinste
Axt hat am meisten Geld reingebracht
verstehe ich nicht das heißt wiren uns
Investment von 40 € am insgesamt 22,80 €
gekriegt ist nicht so ein guter Deal war
eigentlich eher ein Weihnachtsgeschenk
für die Käufer und so richtig an der
Nummer verdient hat eigentlich nur der
Paket Versandservice aber immerhin haben
wir vier unbrauchbare chte wieder
komplett nützlich gemacht eine Axt haben
wir jetzt Bro kann man auch mal gut
gebrauchen den Link zu finanzguro findet
ihr in der Videobeschreibung ich wünsche
euch jetzt eine schöne Weihnachten habt
ein schönes Fest und wir sehen uns im
neuen Jahr ja ciao